foreign
starting off this hour hi Natalie how
are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
hey so my husband and I just started
listening to you
um I needed something to listen to while
I was doing cardio and I found her show
and I told him he needed to start
listening and so we just decided to
Crunch the numbers and I guess what we
had been doing was ignoring
kind of what the debt was because when
we added it all up now it seems awfully
overwhelming and
um yeah I don't know I just found out
I'm going to lose my job my company sold
and they're getting rid of all of their
remote workers
and I'm at home with our four children
and I homeschool them and so I don't
have the ability to just go get another
job
so it was kind of
um
adding fuel to the fire and we're not
sure where to go from here or how to
tackle this mountain that we've created
how much debt is it
um we currently owe 80
881 dollars hey I want you to take a
deep breath because you I can hear in
your voice that you're just you feel
overwhelmed you feel worried you feel
stressed you don't know if there's a way
out of this I can hear it
um you sound like actually you're on the
verge of tears which I've been there
that feeling of
just kind of sweeping it under the rug
and not looking at it and I know for my
husband and I we just kept putting it on
forbearance and putting it on and then
when you come back to it it's like oh my
gosh how did it get this one you've
officially had an oh crap oh yeah yeah
so what kind of dead is the 80
. we also have those
um Fuller loan and actually very little
of it is in credit card debt there's
also another small loan but all of those
are no cards the credit card debt
um we have a small loan on a car yes
okay what's your husband Mike
he makes 83 000. what do you make
um I was bringing home about between 800
to a thousand dollars a month so it
wasn't astronomical
but it was just kind of something that
we weren't expecting to lose my income
um you know in the midst of like hey we
should get out of debt
and now it just seems almost impossible
we're finding the work from home workers
are the first to get laid off
yeah well you also said you're
homeschooling right
yes so I I just wanted to check are you
homeschooling by default because you got
laid off and you thought okay well now
I'll just do this or was that originally
the plan
yeah no I've been homeschooling my kids
from the start
um I have sixth grade
um fourth grade and second grade
currently and our youngest is just one
how much is your house payment
um it's fourteen hundred and eighty one
dollars awesome okay yeah yeah okay
Natalie I'm with Jade here
um yes I can hear that you've had this
thing and it I can hear the uh emotion
that comes with an oh crap moment uh but
I can also tell you uh if you guys are
willing to go bananas I mean go crazy
where your broke friends are making fun
of you type of stuff for about for about
three years we can get you a hundred
percent out of this I can show you how
you can do this but you're gonna have to
get real different
you're going to be living on half of
what you make now yeah you're gonna be
you're gonna be cranking and you're
gonna go pick up some side gigs that you
do from home there's stuff out there you
can do for a thousand dollars I thought
you were making 50 or 60 Grand work from
home or something the way you were
talking but no you can go pick you can
go pick up some side stuff and
um just something else to work from home
he can look at picking up OT or
something else you all can look at what
you can sell uh and then uh you're
you're going to be on a scorched Earth
nothing
budget
you have enough clothes you don't need
to buy any more budget you're not going
out to eat you're broke people broke
people shouldn't go out to eat you're
not going on vacation you're broke
people broke people shouldn't go on
vacation you're going to clean up the
mess so you're not broke people anymore
because it's no freaking fun to be where
you are right now agreed
yeah and we just got done with a no
spend month my husband had a mission
trip planned
this month so
um he kept that because it was already
paid for before we started this but we
definitely we've been trying to
just cinch wherever we can and our kids
are feeling well your your whole your
whole life for the next three years is
going to be a no spin month you're about
to have three no spend years and that's
baby step two and you know I I just have
to add this to it you've had your oh
crap moment of like this sucks I don't
want to live like this but you gotta go
now to the next step of what's the
greater why and you need to start
envisioning what your life is going to
be like if you do the things that we're
telling you to do I want to be like to
have no payments because if you don't
connect a greater why to this I tell
people all the time the stronger the why
the stronger the try so if you have a
very strong why you are going to do your
best you're going to work your hardest
and you're going to stay motivated
through that three years those three no
spend years so that you can achieve that
Vision that you have in your head yeah
so you and your husband are going to sit
down you're gonna do a detailed written
budget every month where every dollar
has an assignment it's called every
dollar it's the world's best budgeting
app we're going to give it to you we're
also going to give you Financial Peace
University our nine-week class that has
helped 10 million people do what you're
getting ready to do and the two of you
you and your husband are going to sit
down look at this and you're going to
start to dream again and you're going to
lay it out and you're going to cut
everything even further than you thought
you did when you did no spend I mean and
then you're going to do anything you can
do to get your incomes up that's legal
and moral we are going to go bananas and
uh for three years if you'll commit
three years to live like no one else
later you're going to be able to live
and give like no one else you won't ever
have to save up for a missions trip
again you can just go
yeah
wow that sounds awesome thank you guys
you can do this you can do this Natalie
it's hard today but each each step that
you take you're getting closer to a life
that's fine that has Financial ease
right now you're in The Angst moment if
I give you this Financial Peace
University can you get your husband to
sit down and watch his first lesson with
you
oh yeah he he's all on board when he
started and then and then download the
every dollar app as soon as you get off
the phone and it goes right in there
with it we're going to give you the
advanced version so you can use the
every dollar app is tied to your bank
and it's going to be really really easy
to do to keep up with the budget and to
start it but the thing that's going to
be hard is you guys are going to
dramatically change your lifestyle
because you're now going to tell your
money what to do instead of wondering
where it went
because you've been living like Congress
for too long
and you got to break the cycle and it's
painful to break the cycle but it is
worth the price because you're going to
be free you're going to be free would it
be like to have no payments
promise you this will work hold on
Austin I'll pick up we'll get you signed
up for it